allez c'est parti sur son antenne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vas y que je suis mort
mais non bonsoir à tous bon soir les
chroniqueuses bonsoir les chroniqueurs
bonsoir le public dans le public plus
vite ce qu'il en reste parce que bientôt
avec le corps un avenir eu son art même
plus le droit de se rassembler ça va
d'aller bien bon alors je suis
extrêmement heureux d'être là
cette cérémonie on fait extrêmement
heureux c'est pas le mot qui prédomine
autres naulleau qui fait la gueule
franchement entre de leurs mots qui me
paie chaud et l'autre la tisbe verdez
qu'ils nous saoulent avec fatou c'est
bon quoi
j'avais pas du tout envie d'être là dans
cette cérémonie des césars de tpm p
alors on va pas se mentir faucon avec
tout de suite un souci parce qu'il va y
avoir un souci d'ailleurs associé que
tifa pas le petit fabuleux fabien le cas
avec son gros paquet bah oui donc je
vous dis tout de suite il sera pas là il
n'aura aucun prix voilà le petit fabien
lecoeuvre donc soyez tranquille ce soir
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
voulaient être à ma place
benhaim par exemple je sais qu'elle
voulait être à ma place mais naim
puisque benhaim veulent piquer ma place
vous l'avez remarqué tous les jours
puisque l essai de rallonger son
émission de plus en plus mais n'alimente
plus
alors au début
sachez qu'il voulait benhaim justement
pour cette cérémonie
les producteurs insisté insisté il
insistait dentiste insisté et puis ben
ali n'a pas voulu le faire pour les
problèmes que vous connaissez bien
entendu vous connaissez les problèmes
gastriques de benhaim donc forcément
elle ne pouvait pas faire cette
cérémonie
et puis après on m'a dit c'est castaldi
qui va animer et là c'est la chaîne qui
a dit non pour les raisons que vous
connaissez
allez je dis que je déclare donc cette
première cérémonie de césar de tpm paix
ouverte
dans la vie dans la vie comme dans les
films
il y a les numéros un et les numéros 2
il y a les premiers rôles et les seconds
les seconds couteaux et bien dans touche
pas à mon poste c'est pareil on les
entend pas forcément mais ils sont
présents pour remettre le césar du
meilleur second rôle
je vous demande de faire un triomphe
pour le seul qui a bien voulu le faire
cédric 6 heures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bonsoir je suis je suis
très émue évidemment d'être avec vous
cyril ce soir ça va plus se servir comme
en musique
merci beaucoup et comme cyril vient de
dire mon texte je vais pas perdre trois
heures je veux dire tout de suite le
vainqueur du meilleur second rôle
je préfére il très ému c'est pour les
nommer d'abord les noa pardon excusez
moi mais les nommés pour le meilleur
second rôle sont il a un truc à dire y
seront
raymond abou d'en libérer des primes et
[Applaudissements]
gagné un seul téléphone et quand je vois
cette beauté dépression va te mettre une
balle dont eric naulleau donc est ce que
j'ai fait au bon dieu pour me retrouver
avec cette bande de renard mais s'attend
à ce que j'écoutais
[Musique]
et maxime gay ni d'en haut on m'appelle
seulement quand aucun autre chroniqueur
n'est disponible dans son rôle pour moi
le meilleur c'était maxime dans son rôle
dans son rôle de témoin dans une roue
avec ses proches au rôle de figurant
[Musique]
le césar du meilleur second rôle dans
tpm paix est attribué à eric naulleau
[Applaudissements]
le faire
m
tous les âges
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
raimu je ne m'y attendais vraiment pas
remerciez adèle haenel d'être resté dans
la salle
je voudrais remercier mon producteur qui
n'a pas pu venir aujourd'hui cyril
hanouna et je voudrais aussi remercier
jean michel maire depuis que je fais de
la télévision avec lui par comparaison
le trouve beaucoup de talent c'est sans
doute là la raison pour laquelle on m'a
remis ces êtres merci merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
que serait donc c'est moi le cinéma sans
costume sans perruque sans accessoire on
va enchaîner avec un césar très
important à mes yeux car j'adore la mode
j'adore les tons pastels pour remettre
le césar du meilleur costume
merci d'accueillir el mout blanchard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mon sens à tous bonsoir je suis
là montré ému de remettre ce titre du
meilleur costume
les nommés sont gilles verdez dans le
rôle de chim on touche pas mon seul up
[Applaudissements]
fabien lecoeuvre en mimie mathy pour
joséphine ange gardien à tous les
dirigeants de bref nous priver d'hanouna
franchement c'est pas mal hein
si vous m'écoutez pas joséphine ange
gardien
mon dos noir jeu
asure id
et pour les costumes
enquête sous tension aux femmes legname
n'a plus connu sous le nom
le bouder
présenté par carole rousseau ou
[Musique]
profession bonjour merci beaucoup
et le césar du meilleur costume est
attribué à gilles verdez
l'animation est nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
enfin
merci vraiment j'essaie de pas pleurer
si on rêvait ça fait des années que je
me bats pour ça il ya une seule personne
que j'aurais remercier ces photos merci
chéri tous ses essayages de perruques de
costumes le week-end à la maison a gagné
chérie je te ramène vers dit quand tu
parles d'un apprenti réalisateur et que
tu lui demande ce qu'il fait en ce
moment il te dit qu'il prépare un film
il te dit qu'il prépare un long métrage
mais avant les longs métrages ont fait
des armes et ont fait ses armes avec des
films beaucoup plus courts à taille
réduite qui s'appelle bien sur les
courts métrages dans la vie on dit
souvent que plus c'est long plus c'est
bon mais c'est pas toujours le cas pour
le meilleur court métrage
les nominés sont dans un instant va le
savoir puisque j'appelle jean-patrick
torchon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soir
jean-patrick rappeler quelqu'un ah bon
on me le dit souvent je sais pas mais
coûte entre vos photos à ses possibles
ou chim et m'écoutais je suis très ému
d'être avec vous ce soir et je pour le
césar du meilleur court métrage voudrait
qu'on voit tout de suite les nommer
[Musique]
valérie bénaïm pour son programme court
c'est que de la télé
[Applaudissements]
valérie benaïm youtube
vidéo regardez comme ils sont beaux mais
chapeau
c'est l'accessoire indispensable à
valérie bénaïm fait le couvre-chef
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner et je vous
dis à très vite
ciao
et valérie bénaïm pour son autre
programme court à benoît y en a qu'un
c'est toujours ses quenottes et les îles
son sac puisque vous êtes le c'est notre
montera donc ce que de la télé ils ne
sont pas quatre non non non ils sont
cinq
et oui et accroche vous êtes là mais
c'est de la merde
[Musique]
le césar du meilleur court métrage
beaucoup de suspense sur cette catégorie
est attribué à c'est que de la télé
valérie benaïm
[Applaudissements]
écoutez je prends sur moi pour pas
pleurer parce que je suis pas les amis
dans la salle mais vous en avez encore
frais et je voulais vraiment dire merci
à tous ceux qui ne quittent pas des yeux
c'est vrai que c'est court mais [ __ ]
c'est bon quoi
merci valérie
charlie chaplin disait quand
intelligence et sensibilité sont en
parfait équilibre on obtient le
merveilleux
comprenez pourquoi on n'a jamais de
merveilleux dans cette émission touche
pas non touche pas à mon poste
ce ne sont pas que des chroniqueurs qui
ne connaissent rien aux médias ce sont
aussi des personnes qui ne connaissent
rien à la comédie malgré tout
l'académie de tpm paix a réussi à
désigner le meilleur d'entre vous et
comme disait l'autre une bonne scène
n'est possible qu'en étant portés par
des interprètes de qualité pour remettre
le césar du meilleur acteur
merci d'accueillir augustin binya mots
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous
on va appeler quelqu'un jeff tuche
peut-être macgyver un mac gyver pas mal
aussi en tout cas je suis très ému de
travail vous ce soir pour le césar du
meilleur acteur de tpm paix les nommés
sont benjamin castaldi ni pour sa
prestation époustouflante dans le biopic
le plus poignant de l'année vincent
miclo nous partons aujourd'hui à la
rencontre de demain son conteneur
devenir une chose est sûre c'est que
d'un sou ne va rien lâcher à part des
caisses matthieu delormeau dans le long
métrage basé sur sa vie intitulé je suis
aussi bons comédiens qu'animateur un
contexte vous êtes viré ça fait chier ça
salaire est tout ouïe salaire assez bien
joué alors attend les dites vous qu on
est l'un de mes marques et eva joly
parce que vous avez déjà vu un mec très
humble et cyril hanouna stupéfiants de
vérité face à une célèbre chouette dans
comme t'y es belle
le retour
[Musique]
merci malade qu'est ce qu'elle est belle
et à ma chérie qu'est ce qu'elle est
belle et
[Musique]
et le césar du meilleur acteur est
attribué à mathieu delormeau
merci beaucoup on a bien réussi merci
merci beaucoup déjà jeu très ému qu'est
ce que je peux vous dire être acteur
c'est être soi mais devant une caméra
paul eluard remercier cyril hanouna qui
croient en moi qui d'ailleurs m'a
proposé d'animer c'est que de la télé
partir du mois prochain
merci beaucoup et puis pour le reste
juste vous dire que je vous aime et que
ça je serai où le mettre merci beaucoup
merci
beaucoup d'émotion bien sûr il est temps
maintenant de remettre le césar ne plus
attendus de la cérémonie c'est bien
entendu le césar du meilleur film
je rappelle que le seul film dans lequel
a joué matthieu delormeau et un des plus
gros flops du cinéma français et en plus
il a été coupé au montage
heureusement dans tpm paie chaque soir
on assiste à des films dignes de la
nouvelle vague et cette catégorie c'est
un petit peu comme le petit rat parasol
dans le cocktail
voyez le petit parasol ou la harissa
dans la chorba
c'est donc le grand final de cette
cérémonie des césars de tpm paix et pour
remettre le césar du meilleur film
nous avons la chance d'avoir une
véritable star du 7e art avec nous
mesdames et messieurs christian clavier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok qu'est ce que c'est que ce binz
non ah oui là je vous reconnais c'est
pour cela je vous reconnais tout et je
suis très émue être avec vous ce soir
les nommés pour le meilleur film sont la
chatte de vercingétorix avec isabelle
morini-bosc tellement impressionnante en
chatte qu'elle sera dans la prochaine
pub pour quitter cannes
à
ah ah
al battar le remake français d' avatar
avec géraldine maillet qui a pris
l'équivalent de quatre heures de
maquillage en deux secondes réel pays à
organiser la coupe du monde de football
de 1938
[Musique]
et tunisiennes rhapsody avec une
composition prodigieuse de cyril hanouna
dans le rôle d'abdelkader mercury
ça va on est
le sait
[Musique]
d
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
et le césar du meilleur film est
attribuée à la chatte à vercingétorix
isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc c'est isabelle morini bosc
oui la chasse à marseille chez la chatte
un personnage historique vient se tue à
faire définir c'est chez la chatte à
vercingétorix me and we will et et je
suis écoeuré je quitte la cérémonie mais
il avait le tenez je vous donne ceci on
me parle je ne peux dire à moraliser les
ont prévenus étaient persuadés d'avoir
le court métrage parce que j'ai toujours
pensé que plus c'est court plus c'est
bon mais je suis tellement heureuse
d'avoir le ce film pour la chatte à
vercingétorix
donc je remercie cyril ne vendra pas
montré la voie forcément à mon âge c'est
une voie d'eau donc il est temps que je
me retire avec mon césar je vais le
mettre à côté de celui de mathieu
eh bien écoutez en attendant trouvé de
trouver un remplaçant à cyril hanouna
place à l'émotion place ce recueillement
touche pas à mon poste c'est comme un
film d'horreur au début du film il ya
plein de monde à la fin du film emmène
la moitié du casting a disparu alors
comme cyril hanouna cette année ils nous
ont quittés
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les chéris voilà vous avez assisté à la
cérémonie des césars de tpm p j'espère
que c'était moins chiant que la
cérémonie des vrais césar sur canal+
bogota